i was like i'm crying i mean this is the
first time i've ever cried to the sex
scene
but let's be honest that is because
of the full circle arc that your
character does like it was so
beautiful having sandra oh like by your
side throughout the whole journey of
killing eve
how did that elevate the experience for
you how does it still
well what's incredible is like and i
feel like
you girls will know what i'm saying is
like sit like sometimes you get to set
and you
you you can act with people and it can
work well and
and it can be great and then sometimes
like a handful of times you can meet
someone and there is so much that
goes unsaid like there's just like a
really strong
connection and and i feel
like i found that felt that was under
the moment that i auditioned with her
it was the same with kim bodnia you know
and
and you know in this series where we we
introduced villanelle's mother
like those relationships where you don't
have to say an awful lot you know we
don't actually
see each other an awful lot when we're
off set but then when when you're on set
and you're doing the material it's all
kind of
it's all kind of fizzing in a way but
she's been
incredible to me you know to think of
where the show started and
you know i remember her and phoebe being
like this show could be
kind of a big thing like you know like
we're just gonna
be warning you so you can like prepare
yourself
and so she's always kind of put her arm
around me in that way
um so yeah i'm interested to see where
where series 4 goes
then do you have like a sort of
shorthand with the way you work together
now does that sort of make any like
really i mean there are so many intense
scenes in killing eve but is that just
so much easier when you
know how someone works or does it not
make a difference you approach every
scene with a fresh
no it definitely does like and i it
makes me think of
the ballroom scene and in season three
you know that was a kind of huge moment
for them
um and when we were
figuring out the dance and the
physicality and it all kind of just
felt together like a a puzzle you know
it was also probably the closest
you had the boss scene but that was the
most physical they'd been with each
other
um which was really beautiful and it
wasn't like we had to really think about
it or just kind of um
it just was you know i think you just
you do you just you just feel it but i'm
very much like that like i don't know
about you guys and how
you prepare and stuff but i like to know
what i'm doing like
you know my lines and etc but then i
very much like to just surrender
on the day and see what the other
person's giving me
yeah yeah that does tend to be like
super fun experiences too
like yeah just and i love like
yeah just the the opportunity for it to
be like a live space
because so much of set life is like it
has to be this and then we're getting
this shot so
i love hearing that process and that you
like that as well
just knowing the foundation and then
just
adding a little bit of flavor to it
that's cool i like it yeah
and that feeling of what you both said
about
steve and about sandra is that just that
feeling of
it's an easy word to use but
collaboration so that you
you can do jobs where everybody's very
nice
everybody's doing their bit but you can
come away feeling
i don't know slightly cold
it's worked and but it's only gone to a
certain level
but when you meet those people that
either it's because you have trust in
them or because you've worked with them
for so long and
you have that shorthand when you get to
share that with somebody
and make something together i think it's
it's my
favorite feeling when that happens and
you get to do that
i think as well that's like as i've
recently done
something that's kind of very relevant
to
today's world that kind of has like a
really important message which i feel
like both of your pieces have
and i have to say like being a part of
that
that has a big message
and it's really important there's a lot
of heart it's like a whole other quality
to the experience but also to the way in
which
i feel people come at it you know
there's like no ego
it's like this thing is bigger than us
all
you know and i i i thought when i
watched both of your pieces i really
really i really felt that
jody was saying how she was in tears
watching hayley's
one of haley's final sex scenes which is
i mean
that's what i was aiming for i was
aiming
i was like i'm crying and this is the
first time i've ever cried to the sex
scene
but let's be honest that is because
of the full circle arc that your
character does like it was
so beautiful to see where she started
like the you know all the kind of
hurdles throughout the way
especially with her relationship and
then that mo
i could at cry out
it was so beautiful but that was because
you know she did the whole
whole full circle yeah i mean also
what's so brilliant haley about
the role of jolene is just how fallible
she is
and we can't always trust her why do you
think it's important that she's
not a hero and she's you know not
perfect
well because nobody is are they yeah i
mean
nobody's nobody's nobody's perfect and
there is never only one thing going on
inside a person
um and just thinking back to
what you said before rihanna about um
what i discovered in the
in the research why i discovered in the
process of playing her
um was it seemed that
the more we shot the more it felt like
um there was another direction that she
was being pulled in
so i think that she's a character who
at any one time has got 14 different
hooks
stuck inside her being pulled in 14
different ways
and i think that she is a version of a
hero
um because i think that she comes
at life she makes questionable choices
sometimes bad choices
destructive choices but she has a
heart that is
insistent on doing what she believes is
the right thing
and of course there's so many moral
questions that come along with that
but it was i yeah there's there's never
just one thing going on with her
yeah um leticia i wanted to just pick up
on
jody's point that scene where althea
sort of defends herself in court it's
incredible and it's so satisfying
because she's holding her own amongst
these men who think they're superior
how important is the show in terms of
empowering the next generation through
education and
process that message it's so it's so
important
i remember when we started to go through
like the promotional stage of it um last
year earlier last year and then
like we were just submitting to film
festivals and getting the feedback and
then
um just speaking to steve quite briefly
and he said
because this is around the time that the
tragic
event of and the tragic passing of james
uh george floyd
and he literally said um
you know it feels like life is
imitating art and art is imitating life
and we didn't plan
for our project to be out during that
time we were just trying to look back
at um what happened the events of the
1970s
and how we can learn from it and able to
have change to move forward
and it was just a poignant time it was
just so important
for us to have that project out at that
time
so i feel in a nutshell it's like
like jody said you know like like my my
fellow uh uh oh i need to say cast
members maybe that's gonna happen
[Music]
behind it um
but yes just like like my fellow um
my fellow cast members um right here
with me
you know we believe that you know
everything has its moment and it's time
in creation june and i mean like
everything
is created for a purpose and we did it
from
our hearts do you know what i mean jody
did her
her project and the story and dedication
from her heart and it just happens that
this is the time where everybody is
resonating with it same with haley
so it's like small acts is just a
beautiful
um a beautiful love letter to our
ancestors to our elders
everybody that's got gone before us and
and and done it
and um and everybody who has
um done it prior um
and for the generation now it's for
everybody past present future
and it's just important to make projects
like this from the heart
and just hope that it will resonate and
touch the generation and touch the
people and it just has and we're so
grateful for that
[Music]
you